les turquie en guerre les américains ce
qui à dix mille soldats cubains serait
en ethiopie le smic à 2400 francs est ce
possible dans une petite entreprise
loket de jacques merlino le temps demain
la météo le prévoit doute toujours mais
moins pluvieux invité du journal
françois truffaut le réalisateur devient
comédien à part entière dans une
superproduction américaine
bonsoir
mais avant de passer au développement de
tous ses titres de l'actualité je
voudrais vous montrer des images qui
vont sans doute choqué les amis de
flipper le dauphin et les amis des
animaux tout simplement une nouvelle
fois il s'agit de massacre par question
de bébés phoques cette fois ci nous
sommes au japon dans l'île
iti ce sont des dauphins qui sont les
victimes de pêcheurs en colère
pourquoi cette tuerie les pêcheurs
disent les dauphins mangent les poissons
que nous attrapons pour vivre il faut
donc choisir et c'est bien vite fait par
centaines les dauphins sont tirés vers
les plages où ils sont tués à coups de
gourdins et de couteaux
un massacre qui a provoqué évidemment de
nombreuses protestations de mouvements
écologistes japonais et qui ne devrait
pas manquer d'en provoquer également
d'ici peu de temps en europe
pour le reste l'un des principaux titres
de l'actualité donc de ce samedi 25
février s'est une nouvelle fois la
guerre entre l'ethiopie et la somalie
pourquoi parce que cette fois ci les
américains viennent de tirer le signal
d'alarmé
selon l'un des principaux conseillers du
président carter il y à plus de 10000
plus bas en ethiopie actuellement de
plus c'est un général soviétique qui
dirige les combats dans la région de la
rare et toujours selon les américains
moscou aurait livré à l'ethiopie près de
400 chars et une centaine d'avions
mig-21 bref les états unis rassurés
pendant quelque temps par les promesses
que leur avait fait les dirigeants
éthiopiens sont cette fois franchement
inquiet devant la dimension
internationale que prend le conflit il a
voulu attirer l'attention de façon très
spectaculaire sur le rôle des
soviétiques et des cubains en head's up
les américains ont plus constate avec
étonnement les chiffres de brzezinski
est passé largement ceux donnés par le
secrétaire d'état et russes en france il
y a environ 8000 cuba en ethiopie aux as
tu parles de 11 vivent plus bas et on a
le sentiment
le conseiller le carter veut pousser
l'administration à plus de fermeté à
l'égard de me dans le cas contraire
l'union soviétique pourrait se servir de
l'ethiopie donewald opération dirigée
contre le soudan l'arabie saoudite voir
l'afrique du sud trois pays bénéficient
de la protection américaine
georges bach fois-ci d'y voir plus clair
dans cette affaire
dans cette guerre entre la somalie
l'ethiopie il ya d'abord cette question
très simple pourquoi est-ce qu'on se bat
exactement hohlandsbourg je vous
explique elsa sur une carte
voilà la frontière normal de la somalie
la frontière reconnue internationalement
voilà la frontières internationales
reconnues pour l'ethiopie or depuis
quelques mois la somalie a attaqué cette
région qui s'appelle l'ogaden le gadel
est une région qui est habité par la
même ethnie que les somaliens c'est à
dire des somalie par la même langue sont
donc partis si l'on veut un peu de la
même tribu mais c'est pour cette raison
que la seule la somalie
revendique cette région qui
théoriquement sur le plan international
et elle obtient la somalie revendique
également une région qui est proche du
kenya qui appartient aujourd'hui au
kenya et qui est peuplée également de ce
maïs est donc l'origine du conflit si
vous voulez mais si les les européens
les occidentaux en général des amériques
a également sont réservés sur les droits
de la somalie
à propos de cette région car il y à une
charte de l'oua est l'un des principes
de cette charte de loyat reconnaît
l'intégrité des frontières acquise par
le colonialisme c'est un découpage qui
peut être injuste et dans d'autres
régions d'afrique il ya également des
tribus qui appartiennent qui sont donc
de la même race et qui sont coupés en
deux entre deux états différents
non pour l'instant le gade n appartiens
l'ethiopie donc officiellement le gall n
appartiennent à les copier d'ailleurs
monsieur brzezinski a douté a dit tout à
l'heure il n'y a pas doute c'est la
somalie qui a violé les frontières de
l'ethiopie il faut qu'il se retire
mais il faut également que les
soviétiques et les cubains kit
l'ethiopie alors après en particulier
cette déclaration américaine il est bien
évident que le conflit dépasse l'ogaden
oui ce qui le réjouit stratégique sur le
plan international très importante il y
a le bab el mandeb il y à l'océan indien
il y à la mer rouge
il y a le pétrole qui vient d'iran les
soviétiques on avait la base de
bergueira en somalie ils l'ont plus
maintenant puisqu'il ya un renversement
des alliances
ils ont d une alliance ou très
importante avec le yémen et adele est là
maintenant il s'installe en est que pi
c'est pour eux quelque chose de très
important c'est même geste inutile plus
intéressante la somalie pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que l'ethiopie est
plus peuplée classe au mali il y a
aujourd'hui 35 à 38 millions d'habitants
on y topi alors qu'il n'ya seulement que
4 à 5 millions d'habitants somalie et
puis il ya une ressemblance entre la
révolution russe de 1917 est également
la révolution qui a lieu actuellement en
ethiopie même si c'est une révolution
sanglante mais c'étaient des masses
paysannes qui était exploitée par
par l'empiré turc 1,2 du négus et donc
il y a une certaine sympathie une réelle
sympathie ditto addis abeba entre les
soviétiques et les éthiopiens merci
gérard le président carter dont vous
parlez jacques s'est dit tout à l'heure
président carter a pas mal de soucis en
ce moment non seulement il ya cette
guerre d'ethiopie
mais aux états unis même tout ne va pas
pour le mieux d'abord les américains ne
sont pas tellement satisfait de ces
décisions selon un sondage de la chaîne
américaine de télévision nbc
la popularité du président carter est au
plus bas niveau depuis qu'il est en
fonction à la maison blanche il a perdu
29 points depuis mars 77
bien évidemment la non ce qu'il a fait
ce matin de la fin de la grève des
mineurs devrait lui permettre de
réaffirmer son autorité
mais ça ne sera pas facile quand même
car cette grève a eu il va avoir encore
bien des répercussions sur l'activité
économique américaine
cela faisait plus de 81 jours que cette
grève des mineurs avait été déclenchée
il voulait une augmentation de salaire
les propriétaires des mines voulait
interdire toute grève sauvage un conflit
très dur et qui s'est même traduit pour
le voyez sur ces images par de violents
affrontements ce matin au finish un
accord de principe est intervenu mais il
faudra attendre au moins trois semaines
avant que la production redevienne
normal d'en ligne retour en europe avec
le nouveau gouvernement espagnol désigné
par monsieur suarez hier soir vous savez
depuis quelques temps déjà que le
ministre chargé de l'économie en espagne
chargé donc d'appliquer le programme mis
au point par le gouvernement et par
l'opposition
ce ministre était passablement critiqué
par les industriels espagnols en
particulier monsieur suares a donc
tranché dans le vif hier formant un
gouvernement à qui les observateurs
applique des étiquettes un peu bizarre
centre centre ou même centre pur de
toute façon il semble bien qu'il y ait
un glissement vers la droite bruno alpin
le super ministre de l'économie
espagnole s'en va il était un peu le
symbole de l'orientation du gouvernement
au centre gauche
monsieur fuentes kintana universitaire
était sa casquette de premier mi
ministre misa par un peu l'équivalent de
notre raymond barre mais aussi une thèse
qui le tannat avait beaucoup trop
d'ennemis
à l'intérieur tout comme à l'extérieur
du gouvernement le patronat par exemple
reprochait à son plan de redressement de
l'économie espagnole d'être trop
largement inspirée par le programme de
la gauche
adolfo suarez le premier ministre avait
bien tenté de rassurer le chef
d'entreprise en les recevant directement
ou par des déclarations apaisantes cela
n'avait pas suffi à restaurer la
confiance à l'intérieur du gouvernement
et du parti majoritaire l'union du
centre démocratique on n'épargne pas non
plus les critiques à l'égard d'une
politique qui dit on un peu glissé le
parti électoralement sur son aile droite
alors qu'est ce qui va changer peut
avoir un état d'esprit on voit par
exemple quitter le gouvernement un
ministre du travail qui s'était fait
remarquer par des déclarations
intempestives sur les pouvoirs accordés
aux travailleurs à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise
et puis d'un autre côté on voit arriver
au pouvoir au poste de ministre de
l'industrie le président le vice
président du patronat espagnol
il n'en faut pas plus aux journaux
madrilènes pour parler ce matin de
virage à droite d'adolfo soirée reste à
savoir en tout cas ce qu'il adviendra du
pacte de la moncloa cette plateforme
d'action économique a signé en octobre
dernier entre les partis politiques et
le gouvernement
car s'il est vide financiers semblent
rasséréné on voit aujourd'hui ce matin
en tout cas poindre l'inquiétude à
gauche france j moins 15 pour les
élections législatives cet après midi au
conseil d'état on a tiré au sort l'ordre
de passage à la télé et à la radio et
différents partis pour la campagne
électorale officielle la campagne
électorale tout court elle et vous le
savez bien vous en plénier parfois a
commencé depuis bien longtemps
mais ces derniers jours il ya un sujet
qui est passé et de loin en tête du
hit-parade de cette campagne il s'agit
du smic du smic à 2400 francs 7 millions
de salariés touchent moins de 2400
francs en france aujourd'hui
ils sont donc intéressés au premier chef
par ce débat et certains chefs
d'entreprise aussi d'ailleurs car peu se
demande comment ils pourraient supporter
une telle augmentation de ce salaire
minimum jacques merlino est allé en
normandie près d'elbeuf faire une
enquête dans une entreprise disons
moyenne à qui ce problème pourrait se
poser
c'est ici dans cette fonderie de
normandie que l'on produit les boîtiers
de direction de la citroën cx une petite
entreprise qui emploie quarante ouvriers
dont une trentaine seraient directement
concernés à une hausse du smic
croyez que ça peut être un risque pour
l'entreprise ici ah oui
pas moyennement mais repart
et cette réponse qui reste en l'air il
vient clairement qu'il appartient au
patron et à lui seul de s'organiser pour
rendre possible cet euro alors le pdg
d'entreprise a fait et refait ses
calculs et son verdict pour être précis
ce n'est pas pour autant sans nuance
il n'est pas concevable de passer à
l'heure actuelle du smic que nous
connaissons à 2400 francs uniquement par
une augmentation de productivité
alors qu'est-ce qui se passera il se
passera pour moi j'ai fait des calculs
sur le mois de janvier 78 ces pages
ça vous fera une augmentation de salaire
à peu près de 48 mille francs et ça me
fera sur un chiffre de production de 600
mille francs ça m'amènerait soit mangé
la grenouille soit à augmenter mes prix
d'environ 8% - grenouille ça veut dire
quoi en clair ce que jamais les pas à ça
veut dire fermer les portes
bon une première alternative ou fermer
les ports pour répercuter les hausses de
salaires sur les prix
la proposition faite par le parti
socialiste de réduire de 200 francs les
champs social de l'entreprise serait
dans ce cas une aide intéressante mais
pas suffisant quarante personnes ce qui
est notre cas ça fait 8000 francs par
mois sur 48 milles qui a sorti rivas 48
et pour cette entreprise qui tourne à
pleine capacité de production une forte
relance de la consommation ne
permettrait pas ce bond en avant du sud
j'ai peur qu'une forte relance de la
consommation ça se solde surtout par une
forte relance des importations dont nous
bénéficierions évidemment pas s'il n'y a
pas de changement politique est ce que
le smic à 2400 francs et rapidement
possible en a c'est une question de
calendrier ordalie ça ya quelques jours
dans les échos je crois que on peut
évidemment il faudra améliorer les
conditions des moins des moins favorisés
mais c'est plus une affaire politique
est une affaire sociale une affaire d
entreprise les entreprises surtout les
entreprises petites et moyennes sont à
bout de souffle
quant à la pression qui était fait sur
elle et c'est peut-être bien cela la
confusion de ses conquêtes dans une
entreprise qui par sa taille s'apparente
à 50 mille autres entreprises françaises
aux hommes politiques qui disent aux
chefs d'entreprise mettez plus justice
dans vos salaires les chefs
d'entreprises répondent plus vite vous
diminuerez nos charges
plus vite nous augmenterons les bas
salaires pas de repos pendant le
week-end pour les hommes politiques en
campagne françois mitterrand et par
exemple à lille ce soir georges marchais
à saint-etienne robert fabre à saintes
adou raymond barre à flers dans la loire
jacques chirac en corrèze
chacun à sa façon son style pour animer
les réunions répondre aux questions
soutenir son candidat
nous aurons l'occasion de suivre chacun
de ces grands leaders et ce soir claude
sérillon et jacques doit nous montre
quelques étapes du tour de france
électorale de jacques chirac
en
c'est fini le chant national et repris
par des milliers de voix ce soir là le
chapiteau dressé près des vagues étaient
à cannes au matin nul ne pouvait
reconnaître en lui l'abri d'un
rassemblement politique
à des centaines de kilomètres de la
place bellecour à lyon déjà les mêmes
gestes les mêmes mots ceux du président
jacques chirac formidablement entouré de
militants on se presse bouscule ça temps
puis on repart en traversant des rues
encombrées en regardant les enfants
courir les commerçants se figer sur le
pas de leur boutique
tout va très vite mais bien heureux
celui qui approche et peut toucher le
grand homme plus heureux encore ceux qui
sont soudain envahi chez eux
ses cris de campagne présidentielle se
répète chaque jour tant pis ce sont les
apparences quitteront et puis bientôt
arrêter le chef du rpr répond question
mais sans trop se soucier des détails à
approfondir ce dossier à partir de la
position de principe dont vous savez
quelle est la nôtre et qui est en fait
une hostilité certaine au mécanisme des
sociétés multinationales
c'est vrai le contact et chaleureux
entre la rue et jacques chirac une
espèce d'entousiasme un peu pagaille
dont on ne sait pas très bien s'il est
ou non bénéfique aux candidats locaux
s'ils apportent des voix
jacques chirac rassemble chaque soir des
milliers de militants de curieux chaque
soir il va leur répétant ses idées ses
ambitions avec une résistance à la
fatigue impressionnante
il est le seul à battre ainsi la
campagne
et oui et demain jacques chirac sera à
clermont ferrand il aura visité son
soixante quatorzième département en
politique et plus particulièrement
pendant la période précédant les
élections législatives il ya les mots et
les choses selon le titre de la de
l'article d'albert du roi publié dans
l'express cette semaine
quelle chose se cache derrière les mots
il est un peu la question que s'est
posée jean-marie cotteret professeur à
la sorbonne
les spécialistes de l'analyse du contenu
des discours politique depuis plus de
neuf ans avec d'autres chercheurs
il passe au crible les interventions
politiques espèrent à l'aide d'un
ordinateur quand vous allez chez le
médecin vous ne l'était plus maintenant
que le diagnostic soit posé sans qu'on
vous ait fait au moins une radio
eh bien c'est la même chose pour les
discours politiques la radiographie des
discours politiques nous permet de mieux
connaître ce que contient le discours
quel est le style de l'orateur et ce
qu'il veut finalement obtenir de
l'électeur si on prend par exemple le
passage de monsieur bart et de monsieur
chirac antenne de quels sont les
observations vous faites
et voilà deux orateurs situé dans le
même contexte à cartes sur table en ce
qui concerne monsieur bart on peut dire
qu'il a un vocabulaire essentiellement
gaullien il y à la fonction du premier
ministre qui la différence avec le
président de la république
et puis d'autre part la france les
françaises et les français et la
relation la communication se fait entre
le premier ministre
la france et les français le reste du
discours de monsieur bart est un
discours essentiellement économique
pour monsieur chirac en revanche c'est
le chef de parti c'est le chef du rpr
qui est portée par le peuple qui va
chercher la souveraineté dans le peuple
et le mot peuple à une fréquence assez
considérable est ce que c'est la fin des
discours engagé très engagé ah oui je
crois qu'il ya une très grande
banalisation de l'ensemble des discours
politiques on peut même dire que c'est
presque la fin des idéologies
cela est dû essentiellement aux moyens
audiovisuels et puis au fait que tous
les partis recherche ce secteur des
lectorats flottement qui n'a pas
beaucoup d'idées politiques et qu'il
faut essayer de convaincre
est ce que le mot parlement revient
souvent dans les discours ou non non
c'est assez curieux pour des élections
législatives que de mots parlement soit
un des mots qu'ils soient les plus
délaissées n'est pratiquement jamais
citer tout se passe finalement comme si
il y avait l'élection du premier
ministre
face au président de la république est
ce que c'est vrai aussi pour
l'opposition c'est vrai également pour
l'opposition on retrouve exactement les
mêmes thèmes
suite et fin de cette rubrique campagne
électorale nous n'allons pas vous parler
cette fois des grands face à face de la
télévision des discours de la radio mais
tout simplement de ce que l'on peut voir
sur les murs de nos villes
ces affiches qui apparaissent au jour le
jour malheureusement pas seulement sur
les murs d'ailleurs et qui est elle
aussi font partie de cette campagne
électorale il ya souvent un message
politique
sur cette affiche daniel grandclément a
essayé de décoder ce message lettres
large mot massif on veut montrer la
stabilité le sérieux le feuillage et
bien vert symbole d'espoir à noter
consignant ses affiches le premier
ministre personnalise son action le
parti communiste fait descendre le
discours politique dans la rue les murs
reprennent les thèmes que développent
les leaders dans les meetings sur les
ondes des nos forces
vrai changement espoirs autrement une
rose fleury toujours dans le point du ps
sans doute pour expliquer que la douceur
et la beauté sortiront de la lutte
les socialistes mettent aussi très en
avant l'image de leurs premiers
secrétaires la marseillaise conduit le
rpr images de volonté d' enthousiasme
image aussi qui se veut sans nuance sans
état d'âme valéry giscard d'estaing et
le bon choix
l'udf et ses composantes prc ds radicaux
c'est et nîmes et bien sûr en avant leur
attachement au président de la
république très à droite où on aime bien
les trois couleurs et on exprime par là
son nationalisme très à gauche on hésite
entre l'esthétisme et le texte simple
peut être plus fidèle à la tradition
révolutionnaire
toujours à gauche avec le fronton
gestionnaire l'écologie et la pelouse
est verte
les revendications des masses aussi il y
à beaucoup de monde écologie tout court
simplicité fraîcheur avec les thèmes
favoris les verts vélo petites fleurs
mais surtout changement cannes des
structures de la société
enfin tous les autres ceux qui veulent
marcher droit
ceux qui clament leur identité ce qui ne
clame plus rien du tout et pour cause
ceux-ci enfin n'a vraiment rien à voir
avec les élections sauf si par hasard un
candidat ingénieux arrive par là et oui
toutes les places sont bonnes les
affiches par milliers aussi en suisse
depuis hier trois millions sept cent
mille électeurs ont été appelés aux
urnes en effet pour un référendum en
quatre questions sur des problèmes
sociaux financiers et écologiques
vous savez que le référendum fait partie
intégrante de la vie politique en suisse
dans certains cantons par exemple les
citoyens peuvent demander un vote sur un
projet sur une idée particulière exemple
les horaires de travail en suisse
l'horaire légal est de 45 heures le
syndicat suisse le plus important
l'union syndicale vient de subir un
échec car il avait proposé ça c'est
vraiment étonnant
la semaine de 40 heures une enquête de
denise bauer la suisse ne finira jamais
de nous étonner les spécialistes de
l'horlogerie est là aujourd'hui des
problèmes mineurs à la suite d'un
référendum fédérale 1 million trois cent
quatorze mille électeurs ont refusé la
réduction des horaires de travail
c'est-à-dire la semaine de 40 heures au
lieu de 45 heures et pour modifier quoi
que ce soit aux règles établies dans le
code du travail les travailleurs suisses
ont deux possibilités le retour aux
conventions collectives ou l'initiative
l'initiative est une espèce de mini
référendum en 76 maintenant pour
monsieur chirac en revanche c'est le
chef de parti c'est le chef du rpr qui
est portée par le peuple qui va chercher
la souveraineté dans le peuple et le mot
peuple à une fréquence assez
considérable est ce que c'est la fin des
discours engagé très engagé ah oui je
crois qu'il ya une très grande
banalisation de l'ensemble des discours
politiques on peut même dire que c'est
presque la fin des idéologies
cela est dû essentiellement aux moyens
audiovisuels et puis au fait que tous
les partis recherche ce secteur des
lectorats flottement qui n'a pas
beaucoup d'idées politiques et qu'il
faut essayer de convaincre
est ce que le mot parlement revient
souvent dans les discours ou non non et
c'est assez curieux pour des élections
législatives que le mot parlement soit
un des mots qu'ils soient les plus
délaissées
pratiquement jamais citer tout se passe
finalement comme si il y avait une
élection du premier ministre face au
président de la république est ce que
c'est vrai aussi pour l'opposition ans
suivrait également pour l'opposition
retrouve exactement les mêmes thèmes
suite et fin de cette rubrique campagne
électorale nous n'allons pas vous parler
cette fois des grands face à face de la
télévision des discours de la radio mais
tout simplement de ce que l'on peut voir
sur les murs de nos villes
ces affiches qui apparaissent au jour le
jour malheureusement pas seulement sur
les murs d'ailleurs et qui est elle
aussi font partie de cette campagne
électorale il ya souvent un message
politique
sur cette affiche daniel grandclément a
essayé de décoder ce message lettres
large mot massif on veut montrer la
stabilité le sérieux le feuillage et
bien vert symbole d'espoir à noter
consignant ses affiches le premier
ministre personnalise son action le
parti communiste fait descendre le
discours politique dans la rue les murs
reprennent les thèmes que développent
les leaders dans les meetings sur les
ondes des mots forts ce vrai changement
espoirs autrement une rose fleury
toujours dans le point du ps sans doute
pour expliquer que la douceur et la
beauté sentiront de la lutte
les socialistes mettent aussi très en
avant l'image de leurs premiers
secrétaires la marseillaise conduit le
rpr images de volonté d' enthousiasme
image aussi se veut sans nuance sans
état d'âme valéry giscard d'estaing et
le bon choix
l'udf et ses composantes prc ds radicaux
c'est nîmes et bien sûr en avant leur
attachement au président de la
république très à droite où on aime bien
les trois couleurs et on exprime par là
son nationalisme très à gauche on hésite
entre l'esthétisme et le texte simple
peut être plus fidèle à la tradition
révolutionnaire
toujours à gauche avec le fonds aux
gestionnaires à l'écologie et la la
pelouse et verte
les revendications des masses aussi il y
à beaucoup de monde écologie tout court
simplicité fraîcheur avec les thèmes
favoris des verts vélo petites fleurs
mais surtout changement cannes des
structures de la société
enfin tous les autres ceux qui veulent
marcher droit ceux qui clament leur
identité ce qui ne craint plus rien du
tout et pour cause
ceux-ci enfin n'a vraiment rien à voir
avec les élections sauf si par hasard un
candidat ingénieux arrive par là et oui
toutes les places sont bonnes les
affiches par milliers aussi en suisse
depuis hier trois millions sept cent
mille électeurs ont été appelés aux
urnes en effet pour un référendum en
quatre questions sur des problèmes
sociaux financiers et écologiques
vous savez que le référendum fait partie
intégrante de la vie politique en suisse
dans certains cantons par exemple les
citoyens peuvent demander un vote sur un
projet sur une idée particulière exemple
les horaires de travail en suisse
l'horaire légal est de 45 heures le
syndicat suisse le plus important
l'union syndicale vient de subir un
échec car il avait proposé ça c'est
vraiment étonnant
la semaine de 40 heures une enquête de
denise bauer
la suisse ne finira jamais de nous
étonner spécialiste de l'horlogerie est
là aujourd'hui des problèmes leader à la
suite d'un référendum fédérale 1 million
trois cent quatorze mille électeurs ont
refusé la réduction des horaires de
travail c'est-à-dire la semaine de 40
heures au lieu de 45 heures et pour
modifier quoi que ce soit aux règles
établies dans le code du travail les
travailleurs suisses ont deux
possibilités le retour aux conventions
collectives ou l'initiative l'initiative
est une espèce de mini référendum en 76
on a demandé à l'échelon national si on
l'était pour ou contre la semaine de 40
heures l'initiative est un moyen qui
semble ne pas satisfaire les syndicats
l'initiative permet naturellement grâce
au scrutin populaire permet à tous les
opposants
retraités petit artisans paysans enfin
tous ceux qui sont pas intéressés
directement par la réduction de la durée
du travail de manifester leur opposition
c'est à dire de déposer un nom dans
l'urne et ensuite de faire couler
l'initiative étonné par l'échec de ce
référendum et pour en avoir le coeur net
nous avons voulu consulter les ouvrières
d'une importante chocolaterie à
neuchâtel rapidement en fait le jeune
fatalement pour les 40 pêcheurs on
dirait
à votre avis l'initiative d'une bonne
formule l'initiative politique non pas
tellement parce que elle sape en fait
tout le travail qui a été obtenu par les
formations collectives
c'est sur cette base en fait un travail
en suisse depuis une quarantaine
d'années il ya un max en accord avec ça
pas d'accord vous êtes ma foi il ya déjà
des idées des souvient mâtinant bats où
il y en a qui vont juste pour rire et
diaporama de sport bien sûr au nom du
père du matin
c'est un droit pas peur
l'intérêt de travailler une heure ou
deux en moins par semaine mardi mais 9
l/100 km et j'ai pu quand même de la
petit jardin qui qu'elles font la paire
car un tel choix pour cette 43e avouer
que la réfection de ce président de la
commission ouvrière risque de laisser
rêveur nos syndicalistes et nos pas trop
dans l'actualité encore ces quelques
télégrammes le décès la nuit dernière à
paris de jean sainteny l'un des grand
gaulliste historique ancien
haut-commissaire de la france en
indochine et ancien ministre des anciens
combattants il avait 71 ans suite des
explosions du 16e arrondissement à paris
deux nouveaux corps de femme ont été
retrouvés sous les décombres d'un
immeuble de la rue de lamballe les
bilans et donc de 8 morts il ya encore
quatre disparus à evreux un élève sans
doute mécontent d'avoir été puni par un
de ses professeurs a sorti un revolver
ce matin en classe et a tiré deux balles
sur gérard burgaud son professeur de
sciences naturelles
le professeur est mort le jeune
adolescent qui s'est tiré une balle dans
la tête a été hospitalisé dans un état
grave
en sport en boxe je vous rappelle que la
nuit dernière à las vegas le français
gratien tonna a été battu aux points en
douze round par l'américain ronnie
harris et puis ce soir il ya du basket
ball il y à du football également voilà
ces matches du championnat de france
monaco au roi à 20h30 et lens sochaux et
puis de la coupe de france aussi match
retour des seizièmes de finale entre lui
c'est énorme et avec l'autre dans le
journal vers 23h30 vous donnera tous ses
résultats ce soir mais dès cet après
midi il y avait un match de coupe de
france entre strasbourg et bastia match
aller cette fois les seizièmes de finale
et l' énorme surprise
bastia à strasbourg a gagné 3 à 0 daniel
kazan
trois bus à 0 bastia en bleu à droite
n'a pas fait de détail cet après midi
face à strasbourg premier but sur ce
centre de larios ce marqué par papy à la
37e minute la même action au ralenti le
temps de dire qu'il manquait à
strasbourg quatre titulaires et pas des
moindres nos vies piasecki domenech et
vers son deuxième but
bastien va le marquer en début de
deuxième mi temps après un remarquable
échanges de balles franceschetti
papilles à la franchise getty rapid
franceschetti papier à nouveau et un
centre de franceschetti repris par
l'avant-centre climat le ralenti le
temps de vous rappeler que krimo et cet
avant-centre qui après une course
solitaire de 50 mètres a marqué le
troisième but de bastia à turin assurant
la qualification de son équipe en coupe
de l'uefa en 23e but de bastia sur cette
balle en profondeur de franceschetti
pour papy centre de papier reprise de
franceschetti 3 0 bastia donc
pratiquement assuré sa qualification
pour les huitièmes de finale avant même
le match retour encore plus important
encore cette victoire doit permettre aux
bastiais de partir l'esprit libre pour
l'allemagne de l'est où ils
rencontreront mercredi soir pour le
compte des quarts de finale de la coupe
uefa
l'équipe de carl zeiss iéna pas de
rencontres du troisième type à tokyo
hier soir pour les responsables du
lancement du film du même nom le film de
steven spielberg il avait il avait fait
de gros efforts pourtant je lis la
dépêche l'oeil au télégramme qui nous
arrive de tokyo où il y avait des
faisceaux clignotants de lumières rouges
bleues et blanches et des ondes sonores
penta phonique
ils sont restés pendant plusieurs heures
au coin d'une rue devant trente caméras
et plusieurs milliers de badauds
et puis ils sont repartis bredouilles
les objets n'ont pas pointé le bout de
leur nez
nous n'avons pas sorti une batterie de
lumière ni un sens particulier mais nous
avons invité françois truffaut ce soir
précisément pour ce film bonsoir
françois truffaut vous n'êtes pas un
réalisateur aussi bien sûr vous êtes
comédiens dans ce film voilà quelle
impression ça fait travailler de l'autre
côté de la caméra et surtout en amérique
très agréable très amusant très agréable
c'est un film à propos des
extraterrestres mais enfin j'ai une
présence terrestre
et quelle invention bon pour vous c'est
de ne plus diriger la caméra mais d'être
dirigé ce que les fois où vous étiez
comédiens en france riez dirigiez quand
même oui c'est ça j'avais tourné dans
deux de mes propres films l'enfant
sauvage et la nuit américaine
et c'est en voyant surtout la nuit
américaine je crois que spielberg à
l'idée de me demander
je pense qu'il voulait un français pour
des raisons de plausibilité aussi pour
avoir quelqu'un venant d'ailleurs simulé
dans cette histoire l'ailleurs est
tellement important et même quelqu un de
nos acteurs pour je ne sais pas pour
donner une certaine crédibilité un rôle
de scientifique
quand je joue claude lacombe un
spécialiste des soucoupes volantes qui
sait que à telle époque se produira un
événement quelque part aux états unis ça
vous a donné envie de faire une grande
superproduction de tourner dans un film
qui a coûté 19 millions de dollars
non c'était ça satisfait ma curiosité
j'avais une très grande curiosité
d'assister un tournage de gens et on se
sent toujours un peu de trop quand on va
visiter le plateau d'un ami tandis quand
on fait partie de l'équipe c'est très
agréable d'être assis da et de regarder
mais ce n'est pas mon genre de film pour
moi parce que je dois faire des films
intimistes qui qui se tourner plus
rapidement que celui là à durer
peut-être plus de cinq mois c'était des
moyens gigantesques mais c'était très
beau à voir c'était déjà un spectacle à
regarder et puis il faut une santé vous
n'avez pas peut-être
voilà une jeunesse parce que spielberg
n'avait pas encore 30 ans quand il
faisait ce film il ya un an et demi
c'est quelque chose comme faire la
campagne de russie de tourner un film
sur les ovnis oui oui oui et nous étions
c'était un tournage en dehors de l'est
vous nous étions 250 personnes venant de
los angeles en alabama et puis dans le
wyoming et c'est énorme
et d'un autre côté nous n'avons pas
assisté à tout le spectacle parce qu'une
grande partie de ce spectacle est
constitué de trucage c'est à dire deux
choses qui sont venus après alors nous
devions temps entend réagir sur des
projecteurs colorés et qui passait et
puis une fois que
venons spectateurs du film nous voyons
des choses merveilleuses à la place de
ces projecteurs colorés
est ce que vous n'avez pas posé à
spielberg la question que tout le monde
doit vous posez ce que vous croyez aux
ovnis je ne vais pas posé la question
mais je crois qu'il s'intéresse surtout
au cinéma
c'est en tout cas ce qui me concerne moi
je ne crois pas aux amis je crois au
cinéma et je trouve que les ovnis était
un merveilleux prétexte à faire du
cinéma un peu comme les oiseaux avaient
été à merveilleux prétexte pour faire un
bon film d'hitchcock et ça vous a fait
changer d'avis vis-à-vis des ovnis non
non non pas du tout c'est du cinéma pour
moi mais du très bon cinéma
mais vis-à-vis du cinéma ça vous a fait
changer d'avis non parce que je sais que
nous sommes américains est grandiose et
surtout actuellement il est dans une
renaissance vous voyez il revient aux
origines du film muet du film
spectaculaire du film qui ce film ne
fait pas peur mais il est tellement
étonnant si vous voulez que le plaisir
est aussi grand qu'un film qui ferait
très peur merci françois truffaut
continue à regarder vers le ciel pour la
météo tout simplement la météo pour
demain de nouvelles plus ils vont
affecter le matin les régions allant de
la bretagne à l'aquitaine puis vont
s'étendre à la majeure partie du pays
quelques orages pourront se produire
dans les régions méridionales
les vents de sud ouest seront forts avec
violentes rafales côtières des
températures seront stationnaires ou en
légère baisse
vous avez donc rendez-vous à 23h30 avec
hervé claude pour la dernière édition du
journal je vous souhaite une
particulière très belle soirée sur
antenne 2